and the european union has to give very
quickly a candidate status and more than
this
has to
invite ukraine to the european union
and all the defensive weapons to defend
your homes we will try to organize
orchards orchestrate
all over the world
we will never leave you alone we will be
with you
because we know that you are fighting
not only for your homes for your freedom
for your security but also for ours
guaranteed
um
we are here because you're fighting also
our fight
you're not only defending your homeland
you're not only defending the territory
of the ukraine and of the europe
you're also defended defending
something which we are calling
fundamental european values
freedom democracy
the the
right of every person
to choose
their own life and every country to be
sovereign and to choose its own path you
are fighting for your lives for your
families
for your country for freedom
but we know we are fighting also for our
lives and for our freedom
we know it and
probably the
main goal of our visit or
main message of our mission
is to say you
you are not alone our countries
stand with you
europe stand with your
country foreign